bunte bild reporterin ingrid rackert ist
mir jetzt per telefon live zugeschaltet
du hast die pressekonferenz zu diesem
fluchtversuch für uns verfolgt war wie
genau ist denn jetzt diese flucht
abgelaufenen von peter madsen ja es war
offenbar sehr dramatisch rasmussen war
gewöhnlich dauert ja wenig gesagt ist
gesagt dass die mitarbeiter alles sehr
stark unter dem ausdruck gleiten und das
psychologisch betreut werden
offenbar hat er eine mitarbeiterin das
gefängnis als geisel genommen und hat
verkündet und die anderen wachleute das
zur beziehung das tor zu öffnen damit er
in die freiheit kommt das war ungefähr
um 10 uhr die wachleute sind dann
nachgelaufen auf der straße der alarm
kam um 10 20 und die polizei fuhr sofort
los um 16 nehmen was wollt ihr denn
jetzt peter madsen genau mit seiner
flucht erreichen dachte er dass er jetzt
wirklich als freier mann herum spazieren
kann das ist die frage die in polizei
gesagt wie man weiß nichts von
irgendwelchen flucht er ist und er kann
ja auch sein dass mitarbeiter soll man
in einem zelt setzen konnte
auch im bodenfeld gesetzt wurde mit der
angeblichen bombe war dann festgenommen
wurde
aber irgendwo ein ziel hatte irgendwo
auf ihn gewartet hat wahrscheinlich ist
aber dass der wille brieffreundin hat
die irgendwann weg bringen wollte das
weiß man alles noch nicht
wie konnte es denn überhaupt zu dieser
flucht kommen und auch dazu dass er eine
geisel genommen hat gibt es
sicherheitslücken vor ort das ist nicht
bekannt aber eines ist klar der im
speedster von denen die hacker rop hat
heute am späten nachmittag bekannt
gegeben dass es alles überprüft werden
muss weil es bereits im letzten jahr in
einem ganz anderen fall eine sehr
dramatische flucht begeben auf sondern
her gefährlichen mann der dann erst
später wurde das später in spanien
festgenommen werden konnte da hat auch
sicherheitslücken gegeben also das ist
ganz
muss laut justizminister überprüft
werden also scheinbar offensichtlich
gibt es da irgendwelche lücken sie dann
doch immer wieder ausgelöst werden kann
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren